[ ♪♪ ]
THIS IS A CAPTIONING TEST. THIS
IS A CAPTIONING TEST.
[ ♪♪ ]
>> HEY!
WELCOME BACK TO THROUGH THE
WARMUPS.
I'M YOUR BOY WITH THE PLUG.
MY AUDIO PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
ON MY ASS ABOUT THAT.
I WON'T DO IT AGAIN.
>> YOUR BOY, D. MILLS.
>> WHAT ELSE THEY CALL NEW.
>> BIG SEXY.
>> WHAT ELSE?
>> BIG DADDY D.
>> OH.
>> IT AIN'T GOING ON, MAN.
>> THE REASON I ASKED YOU THAT
IS BECAUSE YOU SEE THEY CHANGE
THE NAME.
TO MY LEFT, AIN'T MISS A STEP.
WELCOME BACK TO THE WARMUPS.
TO MY LEFT LEFT, HE AIN'T.
>> Stephanie:.
STEPH, STEPH.
>> WHAT'S UP, Y'ALL?
>> I GET TO CALL EVERYONE OUT.
>> THIS IS ABOUT TIME THEY CAME
OUT.
>> THEY CAME OUT.
THEIR BANNER SAYS 17-TIME
CHAMPION.
>> I DID THAT ON CUE FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU A LAKER FAN.
>> I'M THE MOST REALISTIC LAKER
FAN.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
>> EARLIER TODAY YOU ASKED ME,
DEANDRE JORDAN, FOR SABONIS.
>> HE SAID THAT KUZMA -- THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE AN UPGRADE.
>> HE TURNED KUZMA INTO RUSSELL
WESTBROOK.
SO BOOM.
>> THAT'S NOT LOOKING TOO GOOD
FOR HIM.
>> BEFORE WE CONTINUE WHERE WE
ON WITH THIS SHIT, READ --
>> HE JUST MISSED A DUNK.
LEBRON JUST MISSED A DUNK.
>> THAT'S A GOOD SIGN, THOUGH.
>> TAKE THE UNDER.
>> WHY IS THAT A GOOD SIGN?
>> THAT MEANS HE NOT REALLY
WORRIED.
HE JUST RELAXED.
HE WAS WHATEVER.
>> REALISTIC, LIKE IT, READ THE
PROMPT FOR THE PEOPLE.
>> WHAT YOU SHOULD RENAME THE
STAPLES CENTER?
WHAT DO Y'ALL THINK WE SHOULD
RENAME?
>> WRONG ANSWERS ONLY.
>> LIKE WE SAID IN THE
BEGINNING, STAPLES CENTER,
CALLED CRYPTO.COM ARENA OR
SOMETHING.
>> CENTER OR SOMETHING.
>> ALWAYS GOING TO BE STAPLES
CENTER TO US.
BUT WE'LL NEVER CALL IT THE
CRYPTO CENTER.
>> I'M GOING TO ADAPT THE
CRYPTO.COM THING.
>> I'M NOT.
>> THE STAPLES IS -- WHAT IS IT,
FODERS?
THEY HAVE NO MEANING.
>> I'M STAYING WITH THE STAPLES.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S A
CRYPTO?
>> NO.
>> I GUESS.
>> REAL KOBE FANS CALL IT
STAPLES.
>> IT'S THE SAME DUDE THAT SAY
ALONZO BALL SHOULD BE --
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
I'M GOING WALK OFF THIS SHOW AND
NEVER COME BACK.
THAT WAS NOT ME.
>> BE YOURSELF.
STOP FOLLOWING HIM.
HE GETS YOU DOWN THAT RABBIT
HOME.
>> AM I RIGHT?
>> THREE FULL GAMES IN, THEY
TALKING ABOUT HE BELONG IN THE
"G" LEAGUE.
THAT SHIT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE.
>> DON'T BELIEVE THE BS THAT IS
COMING OUT OF THESE DUDES'
MOUTH.
IT WASN'T THE DUDE --
>> YOU KNOW ME.
YOU DO IT DAILY.
NOT DAILY BUT A GAMELY BET WHEN
WE DO THIS SHOW.
>> WE DO.
>> WHO WE GOT, WHO SHOT YOU
TAKING.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE THE CAMERA --
>> YU FOLK ON THIS DUDE?
>> ANTI-LAKERS TODAY.
>> YES, WE ARE.
>> NOT JUST TODAY.
>> YEAH.
I DEAL WITH SOME -- ALWAYS
ANTI-LAKERS PLAYERS.
>> LET'S TAKE A JAYSON TATUM
BED.
UNDER/OVER.
>> I GOT HIS OVER.
>> LET'S PUT --
>> YOU HAVEN'T EVEN SAID A
NUMBER.
>> TWENTY.
>> DANG!
>> HE GOING SO HIGH WITH THE
SHOT.
>> I'LL TAKE THE UNDER.
>> WE GOT AN EARLY ANSWER.
>> 35 DOLLARS.
>> FISHY CENTER.
>> THIS IS -- THIS IS WHAT
SETTING THE COMMENTS UP FOR.
LA FISHY SHIT.
>> WE GOT A -- I THOUGHT IT WAS
PRETTY FUNNY.
OG SAYS HIVE ALERT CENTER.
>> YOU EVER ATE A FISH FILET?
>> I HAVE.
>> YOU EVER HAD AN McRIB?
>> HE NEVER BEEN DOING A
STRUGGLE.
>> YOU ATE A FISH FILET?
>> HELL YEAH.
OFTEN.
>> YEAH.
I HAD THREE FISH FILETS IN MY
LIFE.
>> DAILY.
>> I HAVE HAD AN McRIB?
NO.
YOU HAVE AN McRIB?
MIKE?
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD AN McRIB.
>> HE'S SHOOTING NO-LOOK SHOTS.
LEBRON IS SHOOTING NO-LOOK
SHOTS.
>> HE NOT WORRIED.
ANOTHER DAY AT THE OFFICE FOR
HIM.
>> HE'S PAYING ATTENTION.
>> SPEAKING OF LEBRON JAMES,
BEFORE YOU READ THAT COLUMN, I'M
GOING LET YOU READ IT FIRST.
>> FLOP FITTY CENTER.
EVERYBODY KEEPS SAYING MA  MAMBA
ARENA.
>> SO PREDICTABLE.
Y'ALL BECOMING PREDICTABLE.
>> YOU SEE?
>> Y'ALL WANT TO WIN MONEY OR
NOT?
>> LA MICKEY CASTLE.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I ACTUALLY LIKE LA MICKEY
CASTLE.
>> DO YOU WANT TO GIVE HIM SOME
MONEY?
>> LET'S GO IN THE BAG REAL
QUICK.
>> DISCO MANGO 236.
>> OKAY.
>> A SECTION Y'ALL THROWING
BACK.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> DOWN BY 30 CENTER?
GET THEM OUT.
>> AS A LAKER FAN, WHAT WAS YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT WHAT KAREEM SAID
ABOUT LEBRON IF YOU KNOW WHAT
KAREEM SAID?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN -- I CAN SAY --
>> HE CALLED LEBRON CHILDISH.
>> IT WAS A SENSITIVE S
CELEBRATION FOR SOME.
YOU GOT TO LET THESE PLAYERS
CELEBRATE IF THEY GOING CRAZY ON
THE COURT.
>> I COMPLETELY DISAGREE WITH
IT.
I THINK IT WAS A BIG AIL.
>> THAT'S MY BOY.
>> A CELEBRATION THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN DOING FOR A MINUTE.
SAM COSELL DID IT.
>> THEY GET FINED FOR IT.
GEE PAID HIS FINE.
>> THEN HE POSTED IT ON HIS
STORY WITH THE SAME CELEBRATION.
HE DON'T GIVE A FUCK.
>> DISNEY CENTER, WHAT Y'ALL
THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> IT'S KIND OFF --
>> I WANTED TO SAY DISNEY.
>> DAY-TO-DAY DAVIS.
>> EVEN THE COACH GETS THINGS
WRONG ONCE IN A WHILE.
>> I DON'T THINK --
>> KAREEM WAS A LITTLE
DISCONNECTED.
WHO THE HELL IS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> KIND OF DARK IN THERE.
CAN'T REALLY TELL.
>> RUSSELL'S TOUCHING HIS HEAD
AND SHIT.
KAREEM OUT OF TOUCH.
HE'S OLDER.
BACK IN HIS TIME THEY DIDN'T DO
SHIT LIKE THAT.
>> I'M GOING SAY THE OPPOSITE OF
KAREEM.
I THINK HE'S WAY MORE IN TOUCH
THAN YOU WOULD EXPECT SOMEBODY
THAT'S 300 YEARS OLD.
I THINK HE'S WRONG ON THIS ONE
SUBJECT.
HE'S BEEN RIGHT ON THE MAJORITY
OF THE STUFF.
HE'S BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THE
RIGHT STUFF FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
>> THAT TYPE OF STUFF.
>> EVEN HIS BASKETBALL TAKES ARE
TYPICALLY GOOD.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE THE OLDER PLAYERS
ALWAYS DON'T REALLY --
>> HOW DO Y'ALL FEEL ABOUT
CHARLES BARKLEY BLAMING THE
LAKER SITUATION ON --
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> THAT CAME OUT TODAY.
>> RIGHT BEFORE THIS.
>> YES, I DO.
>> HE SAID THAT ANTHONY DAVIS
PRETTY MUCH IS THE REASON WHY
THE LAKERS ARE STRUGGLING
BECAUSE HE'S NOT PLAYING LIKE A
TOP FIVE PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE.
>> ANTHONY DOESN'T LIKE THE
FANS.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'S PLAYING
LIKE A TOP FIVE PLAYER?
>> HE SHOULD BE BUT HE DON'T.
IT'S ONLY TIMES -- HE'S GOING TO
HAVE MISMATCHES TONIGHT.
I HIGHLY --
>> WHAT DID YOU TELL ME WHEN I
WAS SAYING THAT?
YOU TELL ME THAT WAS OKAY,
RIGHT?
>> HE DID.
>> ONE THING ABOUT THEM ON THAT
SHOW, THEY'RE VERY HYPER
CRITICAL OF BIGS BECAUSE THEY
ARE SOME OF THE BEST BIGS OF ALL
TIME.
THEY ALWAYS GO KIND OF CRAZY ON
OTHER BIGS.
SHAQ AND DWIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY KNOW.
THE BIG POSITION.
>> WHAT DO WE EXPECT FROM DENNIS
SCH
SCHRODER, THE GUY WHO TURNED
DOWN 84 MILLION?
>> ACCORDING TO HIM THAT WAS
FALSE AND NEVER ON THE TABLE.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT WAS NEVER ON THE TABLE.
>> WHY DID HE JOKE ABOUT IT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S -- I DON'T THINK I
WOULD JOKE ABOUT IT.
>> WHAT DID TATUM SWITCH INTO?
>> FREEDOM.
>> I'M NOT CALLING IT.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S HIS NAME.
HE LEGALLY GOT IT CHANGED.
WE CALLED METTA WORLD PEACE
METTA WORLD PEACE.
>> HE CHANGED IT ONE MORE TIME.
>> STOP CHANGING YOUR NAME.
THERE IS DENNIS D. S. 71.
>> HE HAS POINTS IN THE LAST.
ARE YOU TAKING THE OVER?
>> UNDER.
>> OVER.
>> AGAINST THE LAKERS?
>> YES.
>> OH, YEAH.
IT'S THE REVENGE GAME.
EVERYBODY GETS TO TEE UP THE
REVENGE GAME.
>> I THINK HE ALREADY PLAYED IT.
WE ALREADY PLAYED EACH OTHER.
>> HOW DID HE PLAY IN THAT?
>> THAT'S THE GAME I THINK HE
WAS --
>> MIKE.
ME, YOU, BET.
THIS IS YOUR TEAM.
I'M ROCKING WITH JAYSON TATUM
AND THE CELTICS.
I WANT TO DO THAT.
HEAD UP.
I GOT THE CELTICS.
YOU GOT THE LAKERS.
OLD SCHOOL TYPE.
AIN'T FUCK THE POINTS.
>> STRAIGHT MONEY LINE.
>> WHAT'S YOUR -- HOW MUCH DO
YOU WANT TO BET?
>> I KNOW YOU GONNA BE HAVING
MONEY LIKE THIS.
WE GONNA DO 25.
>> WE'RE DOING 50.
>> 50?
>> SHIT.
>> BURGER.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO BET
ON A TEAM.
>> THAT'S CALLED REVERSE
PSYCHOLOGY.
I DUMBED IT TOWN.
I DISRESPECTED HIM BY SAYING HE
ONLY HAD 25.
I KNOW HE WAS GOING TO PROVE HE
HAD MORE MONEY AND I GOT HIM TO
BET 50.
TAKE MY COURSE.
>> ON GAMBLING?
>> ON REVERSE PSYCHOLOGY.
>> I KEEP SEEING LAT DIAGNOSIS
IR -- LEBRON T. ARENA.
WE NOT DOING THAT.
WE NEED SOME BETTER COMMENTS.
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO JUST --
>> I'M JUMP ING RIGHT NOW.
>> I'M PUTTING MY TWO CENTS IN.
>> BLOCKBUSTER CENTER.
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY TRYING TO BRING IT BACK.
>> HEY.
>> EVERY TIME BRON TALK HE GOT
TO COVER HIS MOUTH.
>> HE BE TALKING, HE BE TALKING.
>> EVERYBODY ELSE IS THE SAME
THING.
>> COMMENTS ON LEBRON'S ARENA
AGAIN.
>> HE LET THEM KNOW HE'S GOING
TO INDIANA IN A COUPLE OF DAYS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
LAVERT.
>> LA FLOP CENTER SPONSORED BY
AARP.
>> I LIKE THAT.
THEY REALLY IT.
>> WE GOT LEBRON.
WHAT'S THE STAT LINE?
>> 28-8.
>> Y'ALL KNOW WHO PLAYED ON THIS
COURT?
Y'ALL PROBABLY DIDN'T WATCH.
>> HE ACTUALLY PLAYED VERY WELL.
>> HE WAS RUNNING BETTER PLAYS
THAN US.
>> DAMN.
>> HE BE GOING --
>> THEY WILL.
OVERLOOKED.
>> YOU KNOW HOW FUNNY THAT WOULD
BE IF A RUMOR CAME OUT THAT
LAKERS KENYAN PLAYED.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE TO AT THIS
POINT.
>> YOU ALL THINK BRONNY WILL BE
PRO?
>> I HAVEN'T WATCHED MUCH.
>> HE'S A JUNIOR.
>> THAT'S WHAT I FIGURE.
HE'S GOING TO GET HIS DRAFTED.
>> DIDN'T MICHAEL JORDAN'S SON
NOT GET DRAFTED EVEN THOUGH HE
WAS PLAYING IN COLLEGE?
>> HE WAS AXED.
>> TRUE.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> BRON MAKING THIS SHOT.
WHO WANT TO BET ME?
>> A HUNDRED DOLLARS RIGHT NOW.
>> A HUNDRED?
>> MAKE THAT.
>> I'LL BE WANT TO AND YOU ALL A
QUESTION.
>> I CAN TELL.
>> OKAY.
>> NO NET.
>> DOUBLE OR NOTHING.
>> OH.
>> WHERE'S HE GOING?
>> YOU HIT MY FIST.
HE'S GOING TO KNOCK IT.
[ Laughter ]
>> MAKE IT.
HE AIN'T MAKING IT.
>> WHAT ABOUT THIS?
>> JAYSON TATUM?
GEE WITH HE WENT HAVE A HAD THE
JAYSON TATUM COUNTER.
>> THEY SAY HE'S MADE 17.
>> HE'S TRYING TO GO CRAZY WITH
IT.
>> I'M JOKING.
>> OH.
>> HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO JAYSON
TATUM'S SON, DUKE.
>> CAN WE GET A JAYSON TATUM A
SHOT MAKER COUNTER ON THE BOARD?
>> IT'S TOO LATE AT THIS POINT,
BROTHER.
YOU WANT TO GET TWENTY.
THAT WAS FIFTEEN MINUTES AGO.
>> HE HAD HIM UNDER TWENTY.
>> OH. I DID.
I FORGOT.
>> OH.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> I DID.
>> CAN WE GET ANOTHER LOOK AT
KANTOR'S SHOES?
>> THEY ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
CUSTOM SNEAKERS, THAT WAS NEW
TWO OR THREE YEARS AGO.
>> ANY COLOUR.
>> HE DON'T HOOP IN THOSE?
HE JUST WARM SNUP
>> THE RULE WAS --
>> YOU HAD TO WEAR --
>> MATCH YOUR JERSEY.
>> WHY HAVEN'T THEY EXTENDED
THAT TO OTHER ACCESSORIES?
THEY WERE FINING J.R. SMITH FOR
THE SUPREME STUFF.
WHEN WILL THEY ALLOW A DIFFERENT
KIND OF ACCESSORIES AND STUFF?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY EVER WILL.
>> IT HAS TO BE NBA ACCESSORIES.
>> MORE MONEY GET INVOLVED, I
BET THEY GET SOME TYPE OF
SPONSORSHIP UP.
>> BECAUSE SINCE IT'S SHOES THEY
DON'T HAVE SHOES.
>> WHAT DO THEY SAY?
THEY'VE BEEN VERY POLITICAL WITH
THE SNEAKERS THE PAST MONTH.
>> HE WEARING ELITE SOCKS?
>> THOSE ARE THE NBA SOCKS.
>> OKAY.
THOSE ARE NBA ELITES.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I GOT THE SAME ONES.
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU.
>> IT'S A LOT GOING ON THOSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY STAND FOR
OR WHAT THEY MEAN.
>> YOU REMEMBER THE LAST TIME HE
PLAYED, I THINK HE WORE THE
LEBRON ONES.
>> THOSE AREN'T EVEN HOOPS.
>> THE QUALITY ONES?
>> NO.
HE WORE THE SHOE THAT WAS
TALKING ABOUT LEBRON.
>> ENES KANTER IS NOT.
>> SOMEBODY SAID WEST BRICK
WAREHOUSE.
>> HEY!
YO!
WE'RE OVERNAMING -- WE'RE DONE.
WE'RE DONE.
>> I LIKE A LITTLE RACER.
WESTBROOK.
I LIKE THAT.
WAREHOUSE.
WEST BRICK --
>> BLOCK.
>> CRYPTO.
>> LE CRYPTO.
>> Y'ALL LIKE THE LOOK IN FRONT
OF THAT?
>> NO.
>> IT'S ANNOYING.
>> I DON'T EITHER.
>> SOMETIMES --
>> SOMETIMES IT'S FUNNY.
>> IT'S SO BAD THAT THAT'S WHAT
MAKES IT FUNNY.
>> THEY CALLED HIM LE COVID.
MAYBE TOO QUICK.
>> MIKE LIKE THIS SHIT.
>> ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS --
>> HE DID.
>> LET'S GO MANGO.
>> YEAH.
>> I GOT YOU.
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> HE SOMEBODY WEARS MONEY.
COMING EARLY.
>> DAMN.
>> HE KIND OF SPENT THIS.
>> THAT SHIT BETTER COME IN FAT
"A"s.
NEW FROM A WEEK AGO.
HIT IT.
BRO, IT'S COMING.
>> RELAX, BOY.
MAN, HE'S STRAIGHT FROM.
>> HELL NO.
SOME SHIT.
HE SHOULD CASH AT ME BECAUSE I
LOOKED OUT FOR IT.
JUST JOKING.
TATUM.
>> THAT'S ONE.
>> JUST STARTED THERE.
>> YOU KNOW TATUM ALWAYS HAVE
BIG GAMES AGAINST LEBRON.
HE WANTS TO TEE UP TONIGHT.
>> HE DOES.
>> HE GOT 30 LAST TIME.
>> 32.
>> THAT'S HIS ICON, HIS IDOL.
>> KOBE BRYANT IS.
>> I LITERALLY HEARD HIM SAY IT
WAS KOBE.
>> SAY, NO.
>> HE SAID.
>> I'M PRETTY SURE IT'S LEBRON.
>> Y'ALL HEARD THIS MAN?
>> WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> HE SAID LEBRON'S HIS IDOL.
NO, IT'S KOBE.
I'M PRETTY SURE IT'S LEBRON.
I LITERALLY WATCHED JAYSON TATUM
SAY KOBE IS HIS IDOL.
HE SAID FUCK WHAT JAYSON TATUM
SAYS.
I BELIEVE LEBRON IS THE IDOL.
STAT LINES FOR LEBRON?
>> 22-10-10.
>> YOU'VE CHANGED IT TWO TIMES.
>> HE ASKED THAT SAME QUESTION.
>> YEAH.
>> I DECIDED TO CHANGE IT UP A
LITTLE BIT.
I GAVE HIM MORE.
>> 25-5-5.
>> I NEED TO BE THAT.
>> DONE AT A DE VINCENZO SAID IT
WOULD BE -- KOT.
>> SAY THAT AGAIN?
>> I'M THE REAL DANTE.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE YOU PLAYED ON
IT.
>> WE SEEN THE BACKGROUND.
PRETTY LITTLE THINGS.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
I MEAN, YOU GET THAT WHEN YOU'RE
STAPLES DO STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> I'VE BEEN TO UNITED CENTER.
>> YOU PAY $10,000 TO SIT THERE.
>> GIVE ME A GIFT OF FREE FOOD,
DRINKS, EVERYTHING.
>> CAN WE GET A CLOSE-UP TO
LEBRON'S SHOES?
WHAT THE HELL?
WHAT IS THOSE?
>> LEBRON IS FAST WITH THE
SHOES.
>> I THINK HE WENT BACK IN TIME.
THOSE AREN'T THEM UGLY --
>> I DON'T THINK THOSE ARE
EITHER.
THOSE LOOK LIKE THE NINES.
>> OH, LOOK.
>> YEAH.
>> OH, WEE!
>> THOSE NOT THE NINES.
THOSE ARE EIGHTS OR SEVENS.
>> THOSE ARE HEAT.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> LEBRON MIGHT GET THAT.
>> THEY NEED TO HIT THAT OVER
TONIGHT.
>> MARK SAYS TATUM WILL BEGIN
27-8-7 TONIGHT.
>> WHO SAID THAT?
>> MARK.
>> SCREEN SHOT THAT.
IF MARK GETS THAT RIGHT NEXT
WEEK, WE GOT HIM.
SO MARK, YOU COMMENT THAT, MAKE
SURE YOU'RE HERE NEXT WEEK.
IF YOU HIT THAT, WE GOT IT.
GIVE ME A SCREEN SHOT.
IF YOU SCREEN SHOT IT, WE GONE
NA START DOING THAT.
WE GONNA START DOING WHOSE STAT
LINE IS IT ANYWAY?
OR THROUGH THE WIRE THING.
IF YOU Y'ALL GUESS IT RIGHT,
WE'LL PICK A WINNER.
WHAT ABOUT RUSSELL WESTBROOK'S
STYLE?
THAT'S HARDER.
>> LET'S GET A RUSSELL WESTBROOK
STAT LINE.
WHOEVER CAN GET THAT RIGHT.
>> HIT ON MY PREDICTION.
>> OKAY.
>> 18-7-9.
>> 7-9?
>> 7-9 WHAT?
>> HE DECIDES.
[ Laughter ]
>> WELL, IF YOU HAVE NINE
TURNOVERS.
>> OH.
>> I'M WINNING.
I'M WINNING.
>> HE ALWAYS THROWING SHADE.
>> YOU WANT TO KNOW WEST BRICK
PEOPLE?
>> I HAVE A BURNER.
>> I FIGURED YOU HAD A BURNER.
>> MIKE?
ANYBODY?
>> GIVE ME ONE LAKER, ONE
CELTIC.
>> I'M GOING TAKE RUSSELL'S STAT
LINE AND SAY IT'S GOING TO BE 20
POINTS, SIX REBOUNDS, 8 ASSISTS.
>> WE GOT LEBRON JAMES -- THIS
IS WHY Y'ALL LOSE.
THEY PLAYING FOOTBALL.
>> WHO'S THAT CORNERBACK?
IS THAT RONDO?
>> HE HIT HIM WITH A MOVE.
>> YEAH, THIS IS EXACTLY IT.
>> THIS IS WHY -- THIS IS CRAZY.
>> THEY NOT WORRIED.
I TOLD YOU, BROTHER.
THIS IS ANOTHER DAY IN THE
OFFICE.
>> ARE WE GOING TO SEE A FIRST
FIGHT BETWEEN LEBRON AND ENES
FREEDOM?
>> I LOVE HOW LEBRON SAYS HE'S
NOT THE TYPE OF PERSON.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE MARCUS
SMART.
>> Y'ALL GOT A GAME.
>> NO BULLSHIT.
I AM LITERALLY -- I'VE SEEN THE
LAKERS DO THIS.
BUT I SAW Y'ALL DO THIS FOR
ANTHONY DAVIS.
I SAW Y'ALL DO THIS.
I DIDN'T KNOW Y'ALL WAS DOING
THIS.
>> GOD.
>> YOU REMEMBER HE WAS IN THE
BUBBLE.
>> YEAH.
>> BECAUSE I WON A CHAMPIONSHIP.
YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
WHEN YOU WIN IT.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
YOU'RE NOT WORRIED.
>> WHY.
>> YOU'RE WORRIED AS A LAKER
FAN.
>> PEOPLE HAVE DROP THE FLAT
LANDS.
>> BROOKLYN STARTS.
>> ONE QUARTER COMEBACK.
>> HE MIGHT HAVE DID THE OVER.
THEY SAY K.D. HIT A BIG SHOT.
>> AD NEED TO LEAVE 25-OF-15.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT # 15.
>> 24 POINTS.
>> WHO?
>> I'M SORRY.
K.D.
HE HAD 24.
BUT THEY ENDED UP CLOSING IT
OUT.
>> JOVON CARTER AGAINST THE
MAVERICKS.
YEAH, MAN.
>> LUKA COMING IN AT 40 POUNDS
OVERWEIGHT.
>> OWEN --
>> MUSCLE.
>> OWEN GAVE US MULTIPLE STAT
LINES.
HE SAID TATUM'S GOING TO HAVE
SIX REBOUNDS, FOUR ASSISTS.
DENNIS SCHRODER'S GOING TO DROP
24 AND 10 ASSISTS.
WESTBROOK IS GOING TO HAVE
22-10-10.
'MELO AFTER THE DOUBLE NEGATIVE.
LEBRON'S GOING TO HAVE 26-6-8.
DAMN, THIS IS A HIGH SCORING
GAME.
AD IS GOING TO HAVE 25 AND 10
REBOUNDS.
>> MAYBE A STAR PLAYER.
MAYBE HE'S NOT SAYING.
>> NO WORRIES AT ALL.
>> THIS WILL BE A HELL OF A
PARLAY.
>> HE GONNA LOSE SOME MONEY.
>> I'M KEEPING UP ON THE SNAP.
>> I LIKE AUSTIN REEVES.
>> I DO.
>> HOUSE OF HIGHLIGHTS BE
PUSHING HIM.
HE NOT LIKE CARUSO.
>> I WISH HE HAD THAT CARUSO
DEFENSE.
BUT HE --
>> HE DOES PLAY SOME.
>> HE'S NOT CARUSO.
>> GIVE HIM SOME TIME.
>> I'M GOING TO LOOK AT THE
KICKS LEBRON WALKED IN WITH.
LET'S ROLL THAT.
I'M TIRED OF LOOKING AT LEBRON
PLAYING FOOTBALL.
WHEN HE LOSE HE GONNA BE PASSIVE
AGGRESSIVE IN THE POST GAME
INTERVIEW.
TALKING ABOUT WE NEED TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES.
THAT'S HOW LEBRON BE.
HE JUST SAY SHIT TO HAVE
EVERYBODY IN THE LOCKER ROOM ON
PINS AND NEEDLES.
WE GOT GUYS, THEY DON'T WANNA
PLAY.
GUYS NOT MAKING SHOTS.
IT'S NOT MY RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SHOTS.
THEY'RE GROWN ASS MEN.
>> OKAY.
>> VARSITY JACKET.
SOME FORCES.
>> LOW FORCES.
>> OKAY.
>> I THOUGHT THEY LOOKED HIGH.
>> DON'T DISRESPECT LEBRON WITH
HIGHS.
I LIKE THAT.
A MAN WHO HAS EVERYTHING WALKS
IN WITH NOTHING.
>> THAT'S A METAPHOR FOR LIFE.
IF I WAS SINGING THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM, STAR SPANGLED BANNER,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
IT'S ALMOST GAME TIME, SHOUT OUT
TO THE DUDE WHO WON MONEY.
MIKE D. MILLS.
>> DISCO MANGO.
>> THAT'S A FIRE NAME TOO.
I LIKE IT.
>> WE GONNA SEE Y'ALL NEXT WEEK.
WE SIGNING OUT.
IF THOSE STAT LINES ARE RIGHT,
YOU COMING BACK AND WIN IT.
THIS IS "THROUGH THE WARMUPS"
AND WE WILL SEE YOU ALL NEXT
WEEK.
>> PEACE.
[ ♪♪ ]
>> SHOUT OUT.
>> NARWAL WATCH THIS.
YOU KNOW.
[ ♪♪ ]